but Blake and John are they are  terrified of you look at this oh yes  it has a huge fan base and they are  fervent and if they show up to vote  we're all in trouble 100 are you scared  at all now what I'm not afraid of the  fan base where are they at look at look  at me where's the camera bring them away  Ariana fan bring it on I'm not afraid  he is so afraid of our honest fan base  um but we said this when you came in I  mean it was apparent literally the  entire audience was screaming like we  have no chance like it was like I know  that that's true well I'm just saying  like I think that's true I mean but  you're like you're a huge star I don't  know  Kelly Clarkson what  [Applause]  [Music]